well country legend Loretta Lynn was
just 15 years old when she got married
and now the Coal Miner's Daughter is 83
and still going strong
Loretta's first album in 12 years just
dropped today and we talked her about
everything from her music to her
politics and why she thinks Donald Trump
could be President
can y'all say President Trump yes if he
keeps his mouth shut on a lot of things
she's an icon who says what she thinks I
think I worked probably harder than
anybody in the business people to
director daggone lazy to do this new
this guy thanks miss Loretta go in at
the door sir
so this Pharrell and she's Miranda's
Idol Loretta always just said exactly
what she was going through right then
and her music and that's why it
resonates with us Miranda and me we're
kind of the same half the same Loretta's
got an opinion on everybody listen to
her take on Taylor Swift she wanted big
pop hater get it girl that's what you
want
I'm boughs Papa's cornbread country to
the core we first met her in 1982 when
she was 50 when I was a little girl
growing up I never dreamed about ever
being a country singer growing up poor
today Loretta lives in this Tennessee
mansion the place is honey I'm telling I
did see a woman on the balcony of the
big mansion three o'clock in the morning
you could hear them high heels click
click click click going up the stairs
her new album is titled full circle and
tonight American masters Loretta Lynn's
still a mountain girl premieres on PBS
and last night she brought the house
down on Fallon and she
yeah still hittin the road we hope she
goes on forever oh I feel great and I
love to get out there and sing I have
people from 10 years old to 8